it's been a whirlwind here for fifth
harmony and their success isn't going
unnoticed earlier this month the
Billboard magazine compared them to
Destiny's Child it's absolutely insane
because there's such a huge inspiration
to us in our careers honestly and they
are so talented so incredible so to even
be remotely compared to them is just
amazing because they really have
inspired us a lot that was an honor to
be called that like what is what what
ladies also had a sense of humor about
this shot from the spread look closely
Allie Brooke has to write beats oops my
right foot would like to say thank you
to all the people that know it was so
funny um honestly and sorry I'm like
blinking a lot I don't know why it was
really funny but yeah so good at
Saturday's kiss FM Wango Tango concert
5h also teased new tunes off their
upcoming album 7/27 there's a duet with
Missy Elliott that happened did you guys
call her did she call you called her
personally but yeah it was a grew up
listening to her like watching her music
videos and everything that she did yeah
of course so it's really awesome to even
have her it's an honor such an honor to
have all these people collab with us we
have ty dolla sign Fetty WAP Missy
Elliott and the fact that these people
are even willing to be on a track with
this is such an honor dude and we're
just working we're just trying to work
really really hard and make this album
to its best